I think generally culture is living in
very much a victim mentality
identity politics spiral of like there's
always something to glom on to to
um defer accountability and
um I think that's a lot of one of the
biggest problems
everyone's a victim of something right
and there's a reason for lacking success
or lacking progress or lacking lacking
whatever it is um that you that you want
to put your finger on there's you could
come up with a reason right and I think
probably in my own life accountability
has been what I've most been been most
proud of like whether it's
accountability for my emotions
accountability for my reality that I
live in in every space it's like it's up
to me and as soon as I stopped looking
to other people to help me make that
happen then it's like pretty freeing
where did you get that from
where did I get that from
yeah
um probably enough time pointing the
finger probably enough time
I'm pretty like good in the professional
realm of things but personal realm when
I stop pointing the finger at other
people and started just asking what's my
part in this then
if you become liberated happier isn't
that amazing yeah yeah and most people
don't live life that way it's it's
somebody else's fault that they're at
where they're at yeah right and that's
what I think a lot of society has
conditioned themselves to believe and
understand now it's like you know if
that guy over there has money then he's
bad because money is the root of all
evil or uh if that guy over there is in
fit in a healthy shape with six-pack abs
at you know 50 years old what's he
trying to compensate for you know why
does he think he needs to do that who is
he trying to impress right sort of so
you know there's all this all this
pointing and sputtering at you know
different people out there and envy and
jealousy's uh it's a horrible emotion
and I see a lot of it out there you know
like
um I obviously have an online presence
like I'm getting seven to ten million
views a month on the stuff that I'm
doing so I get hate right and you know
I'm always girls and some girls you know
well you know we'll figure out if you're
a hater if you're a Laker by the end of
this podcast I'm fascinated I'm not I'm
fascinated so yeah so it's much more on
liking than hating because I'm
fascinated I love the discussion got it
yeah so so I get hate and I get love
obviously but but I mean like the haters
are the ones that I'm always interested
in because it's like okay well if this
person's criticizing you then where is
this coming from Derek like would I want
to trade my life for your life what do
you do for a living what have you
accomplished what do you look like what
are your views and opinions and it's
funny because you know there's a digital
footprint so you can click through on
people you can click through on them on
social media on YouTube videos you can
see what they subscribe to what they
watch you can see what their tweets are
all about on Twitter and it's pretty
obvious to me that that jealousy and
envy like all this hate always comes
from beneath you because nobody ever
gets jealous of a loser people only get
envious and jealous of somebody that
they want to be or to be like or to have
things that they have sort of thing so I
find this I find this Dynamic
interesting today where it's like people
spend a lot of time effort and resources
trying to bring bring somebody else down
and it's like wouldn't it be a lot
easier just bring yourself up to their
level well what does it take to do that
what does it take in your life I'm
guessing obviously you've you're in that
space so what is it that tips them over
because I think some of the problem is
it's not that people don't want to get
better it's not that people don't want
to want the pathway forward they don't
actually know they need it yeah that's
an interesting question because it's is
it's they don't need it they don't know
how to do it has it has it been uh like
squeezed out of them like is it
something that's been engineered out of
them through uh you know through their
upbringing
um one of the things that's changed
culturally over the last couple of
generations is we have more kids today
raised in a single parent household than
we ever have in in the entirety of
History
um most households in my dads and
grandparents generation obviously were
not single-parent households most
households today are single-parent
households and they're and they're
mostly moms well they probably
progressively gotten smaller just in the
community scope to further back would be
like grandparents and uncles and aunts
and cousins and like it's
all the way down to one parent
essentially yeah and um they're not
doing a great job I mean you know the
results are in most like the vast
majority like when it comes to like high
school year kit kids
um the vast majority of gang activity
teenage pregnancies runaways uh terrible
marks in school incarceration they're
all from single parent households and if
you remove the father from the household
what do you think is going to happen
right there's an interesting story that
I heard one time about
um the almost Extinction I think it was
a white run white rhinoceros in Africa I
might have butchered you know the Reed
of rhino but it is but it was a rhino
and poachers were were killing off male
adult elephants for their ivory tusks
and what ended up happening was the
young male elephants were charging these
rhinos just out of fun you know just out
of shits of Giggles because there was no
adult males to reel them in and keep
control of them so they found when they
they started to reintroduce adult males
and they and they got rid of the
poaching the white rhinos stopped dying
off because the young adult males
stopped charging and killing them so
like you need men and women in a good
Society it's you know it's required and
the problem is is that you know guys
were considered the head of the
household at one point right they were
the leaders they were the ones that were
respected and looked upon but today men
are mocked I mean I grew up on a steady
diet of sitcom you probably saw shows
like uh you know Home Improvement Tim
Taylor The Cosby Show stuff like that
when you're growing up and the fathers
really always portrayed to me as a
bumbling idiots right and I think you
know that's just one of the small
elements that have that have contributed
to the to the change and the decline of
the West right
um
time to talk about roles it's something
I'm curious in my own life about I've
asked many people that but like what is
a man and a woman's role in a
relationship
that's a great question because those
roles they try to overlap them now you
know one of the words that really grinds
my gears is partner I don't know about
you but whenever I hear somebody say oh
my partner okay is it your husband
uh are you lesbian you know
is she a woman like why are we using the
word partner like why aren't we using
husband my boyfriend my man my woman my
wife my babe you know whatever it
happens to be
um I mean it would be it'd be to share
it'd be that you know like you know for
instance
say you're married you have kids or
you're together you have kids whatever
it is and you know the the dad is like
I'm gonna babysit it's like no now
you're gonna be a father you're gonna
you're not gonna babysit like they're
like you know do you think that I always
have do I always have to wash dishes do
you always have to take the garbage out
you don't I can do that you can you can
wash dishes like it doesn't I think
partner is implying that it's we're in
this together and that we share we pick
up the pieces when we need to and it's
not always going to be
these roles for this person these roles
for that person we're going to help each
other that point of being a partner yeah
that's that's the ego investment that
you have in that story so let me sort of
um you know dive down that rabbit hole a
little bit because I think for the vast
majority of History
um a friend of mine calls him pink jobs
and blue jobs right like he does a Blue
Jobs wife does the pink jobs
um he's cut in the grass shoveling the
snow uh taking care of the card
maintenance you know she's running the
kids to the doctor's appointments uh you
know preparing meals and stuff like that
so and that's fine because you know men
have strengths and and women have
strengths agreed and there's a reason
why the vast majority of men
um
are in fields like Roofing oil rigs
um you know construction engineering all
this sort of stuff and women are more
into nursing and child care and teaching
and stuff like that and that's like one
of the you know big complaints that
feminism has about you know the world is
all women are paid 70 or 80 cents on a
dollar for every dollar that a man makes
sort of thing it's like no if you're
working you know 14 days straight on an
oil rig you know 12 hours a day and
you're working at a child care center
for seven hours just you know feeding
some kids and you know hurting some cats
in the playground he's probably gonna
make more money than you so let's not go
there right so I mean I got paid more
than most men so I I don't subscribe to
that argument yeah and there's certain
Fields where women do get paid more than
most men like I know a guy usually race
car driving maybe you're right um I
don't I don't know much about what that
is but there are but I mean you also had
GoDaddy sponsorship she had a lot of
other opportunities to increase your
income too right but there are certain
Fields where women do make more money
than men in the exact same field like I
have a friend that spent a few years in
the porn industry and the amount of
money that women make as porn actors is
significantly more than what men do
right so because there's more people
watching him it's just exactly yeah
there's more demand because that's what
people are watching not watching the
dude
um so as far as like the roles goes you
know back to your original question I
mean for you it's different though
Danica because I like one of the things
that I noticed with you that other women
do that you don't do is most women start
sentences with I feel like
and you'll notice this when you go back
and you watch this video but every time
you start a sentences I think and
rational thought comes from I think so
you're going to have a different
perspective from the majority of women
that want to be wives that want to be
stay at home and make babies and take
care of a household sort of thing
because they're going to do the I I feel
like I feel like this and that sort of
thing the other thing so you'll have a
slightly different perspective and
there's going to be in a ideology of
partnership in some of your thinking
because of your accomplishments because
you're successful too right so I get
that that's where you're coming from but
for most of society it's it's usually
Blue Jobs and paint jobs right yep
that exists at home for I mean like when
I'm with someone that happens yeah you
know he's like no no great let me take
that garbage I'm yeah I'm gonna get that
I'm like okay there's a certain degree
of ownership that you have to take in a
relationship as a man like one of the
things that I found myself doing over
the years when I kind of Dove down this
rabbit hole and got a new evil psych and
the whole red pill stuff it's like if
I'm walking down the street with my girl
and she's on the outside close to the
road where traffic's coming I'll flip
her around and put her on the inside and
I'll stand on the outside to protect her
right so that's a man's role I would not
expect a woman to do that like that's
not equal partnership that is my job to
protect you right so
um you know there's certain things where
it's like sure you know you want to take
out the garbage take out the garbage
it's fine right but I'm not going to ask
you to shovel the driveway or operate
the snow blower things like that I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out